yo brooklyn nine nine episode three
today
a dumb son of a [ __ ] everyone for being
here this is the most like
random thing we decided to cover and
it's been a delight thank you so much
subscribe and hit that bell if you
haven't done that already hit that like
button
helps get the video promoted full length
watch alongs over at our patron where
there's a bunch of other crap there too
where the same tier you get reaction
highlights and watch songs included and
you're
gonna hear me say this imagine me
i'm more sick of music just go there
check it out we won't have to say it
anymore no we still will because there's
always
more to bring to your patreon and
another thing we'll always say is thanks
to pratham jindal for editing the
highlights down
you're a you're a great cop i don't
really
know that well for thumb but you're
you're a good editor thank you for that
you're a credit to the force
hey gang so the time of filming this uh
episode one
is currently blocked uh i have submitted
a dispute and i got a backup plan if we
do not
win said dispute but for those who have
been asking where episode 1 is for
brooklyn 99
in the disputing process but who knows
maybe by the time you catch
this video the dispute will have been
gone and it's fine or the backup plan
worked we'll see
for the last time the best cop movies in
order
training day lethal weapon die hard is
the best cop movie of all time
robocop it's got everything i like
gratuitous violence
[Laughter]
excellent pause so gather round for the
greatest cop film of all time
please refrain from texting during our
presentation
alright so there's hitchcock and there's
an old hooker oh
poor hitchcock that's the best part she
comes back
takes the wallet and here she goes
poor hitchcock two to the nuts where are
we on the adam street burglary
we are very close captain aside from a
complete absence of evidence suspects or
leads
and the vicar street aggravated assault
stalled out
and the callaway robbery also remains
unsolved due to
a lack of solving it by me sounds like
someone's in a little bit of a slump
i'm not in a slump you're not scoreboard
i don't slump people oh
i'm concerned that the open cases mound
of garbage on your desk has become so
much higher than the closed cases mound
of garbage
all right sir let me hit you with a
little analogy are you familiar with
race cars
formula one or stunk that's already way
more than i know
last sunday her grandson judd reported
she went out for bagels and never came
back
this morning we picked up an old lady
matching her description exactly
i showed her pictures of judd and she
said and i quote
that's my grandson
what did i say about doing voices i'm a
storyteller sir
it's my craft anyways grandson's coming
in
they reunite and i throw another case on
the old solved it pile
no yeah yes the d.a wanted me to
personally thank you for your work on
the j
street drug bust that's why we do this
sir for praise
if you'd like to head it up is that a
rainbow disco ball on his desk
i won't just head it up i will head and
shoulders it up
i will dive in swim around it and just
be
all together good with it be more
articulate when you speak to the
children
yes sir i will make better mouth
how every year the precinct does that
junior police program seminar what about
it
captain specifically asked me to run it
this year and assign you to do it with
me here's the info
now i got to read something greetings
fine
i guess i can help you with those
at-risk kids i don't need your help
you're not a cop so i'm not really sure
you could help okay
no hard feelings but i hate you not
joking
bye ah
mr and mrs torino i'm glad you're here
may i present to you
i have no idea who this lady is no she
recognized you this is helen
who's helen oh it's my husband
salomon i'm i'm not really your husband
you're so much shorter than you used to
be what did the japanese do to you
oh
it looks like this case remains unsolved
peralta
i'm in a slump
p malls man okay
this is the junior police program that's
petey
davis immediately noticed it
i know you think getting in trouble is
cool
but let me show you what can happen if
you continue down this path
hey yo i'm an at-risk kid and i think
it's
oh why does the kid selling drugs sound
like he's black
he's not well why not are you saying
that black people
can't sell i drugs
why can't black people sell drugs i'm so
[Laughter]
confused
[Laughter]
there's the looks he gives oh that's
hilarious
um i'm building this dollhouse for my
girl it's her birthday tomorrow always
so surprised how buffy is
where do i fix the prince's tower boyle
where do i
fix it
black people can still drive some stupid
and therefore we'll have a ton of
paperwork which i know you hate
i have a murder here with no leads and
no evidence it's unsolvable
oh no i have no paperwork
you had me at no paperwork that was the
very end of the sentence
[Laughter]
so funny so you haven't solved any of
your old cases and yet you've taken on a
new one
i mean shouldn't you at least solve this
helen storino missing grandmother case
first or i could solve this super easy
one get my mojo back and move on to
catching the zodiac killer am i getting
ahead of myself no you are not jake
rabbit i like jake hammer better let's
go
i was just practicing my minuets but
i'll hold it down all right flute man
who else is in this apartment where's
the dealer
i live here alone with my birds drug
mules they're
bird mule drugs drug bird mules
apartments
here i bet it's a silly kid's down the
hall they love prank calling me
the only drugs in this apartment are for
my heart my liver my kidney my salivary
glands and my penis and my feet
oh the bird pooped on your shoulder no
wait oh
pooped on your head then dripped on your
shoulder
luck luck it's good luck
that's just something people say when a
bird poop's on you to make you feel
better because it's terrible
four coming in oh come on ah
i knew it crime scene this guy comes up
out of nowhere
confesses so helps me track down his
accomplices
that is so great man looks like
everything's coming up hitchcock
hey jake you busy yes i very clearly am
busy
the medical examiner's office just
called they missed philly please
oh the da's gonna have to dismiss your
last two buzz
great and the slump gets worse i don't
think it's a slump
honestly you are straight up cursed good
to know
no can you hand me a paper towel please
tina
there's no more left yeah that sounds
[Music]
right
hey you're dripping on my carpet oh
don't worry sir it's just urinal water
ah you could eat off his shirt why would
i ever eat off his shirt
look sir i don't know what's going on
but i think i'm cursed of course though
the freakiest things have been happening
to me i mean i can't solve a case to
save my life
birds are unloading on me left and right
and two seconds ago
hey sorry do we have any old t-shirts in
here
first that happened to a friend of mine
back in the 1-8 detective smith
he thought he was cursed and because
cops are superstitious
the whole precinct thought he was cursed
no one would go out on calls with them
he responded to a riot at a gym without
backup and got beaten up by a girl's
volleyball team
girls are so scary you can digitize old
files with scully you're benching me
and how long will that be could be a
week could be a month it could be a year
it could be a decade i don't know how to
connect with these kids
they're mean and shallow and respect
nothing i mean what kind of person would
they even listen to
hitchcock stop bringing your food in
little tupperware containers it hurts my
fingers when i'm trying to open it
sorry hey
coming in handy rosa and i think it
would be great if you talk to the kids
um i thought only cops could help in
this case not being a cop might actually
be better
that's true in all cases cops are the
worst
enter the numbers from this report into
the corresponding boxes on the screen
then fill out these fields and i'm in a
coma
hey hitchcock help me out man i'm so
bored let me jump back on that murder
with you
no i got it
you're contagious everything could fall
apart peralta leave hitchcock alone
come here
touch with smitty he says that you
should rub this rabbit's foot with your
left forefinger and your pinky like this
for good luck yep it's definitely
helping i can feel it
the curse is lifting off of me ah hand
cramp
rub rub rub oh fairy princess castle has
defeated me
i'm gonna grow with man hands and a man
brain i should be able to put together a
dollhouse in less than four hours
this screw has three pointy sides
and there's wheels what kind of
castle has wheels oh god
no no no no
no
yes 18 hey
wait a minute
hey just head into the can take the
rabbit's foot
hey what's going on well i'm not allowed
to leave my desk so we have to meet in
here
so what you're saying is that this is
kind of a no for the last time charles
we don't need a clubhouse
[Music]
you know what i'm thinking no clubhouse
charles's favorite app let holt see you
but if my hunch is right the slump is
over
come through for me boyle you know i
will all right i'm just saying you put a
couple of leather chairs in here
go ew
how'd you ever want a clubhouse
especially that bathroom
you're troubled or at risk or bad
dressers
is that a trucker hat still come on
my life turned around when i found my
passion
and today well i hope to inspire you
with it
[Music]
what are we thinking i think i speak for
everyone when i say your weird dancing
was just weird fine cops make 52 000
a year you never have to stop it and you
get to carry a gun
who wants in boom boom boom boom how did
you know that would work
that's what made me sign up when i was a
kid you did this program
mm-hmm yeah it does not work
oh they're here
fantastic too dramatic no hi
no
i know what happened to your grandma
nothing the reason i couldn't find her
is because she never existed
i had detective oil make some calls and
it turns out you've done this before
five missing persons reports in five
different states recognize this
what are you accusing us of probably
insurance fraud definitely filing a
false report and obstruction of justice
hmm hmm
[Music]
blammo camera strikes again camera
strikes again
the curse is over the slump is done jake
is back permission to take a selfie of
the two of us sir permission denied
too late
all i know is my mind was so numb from
doing all that boring data entry that my
brain kind of rebooted and i had an
inspiration
about one of my old cases
and i now see that that was your plan
all along and that you're capable of
smiling
detectives have their ups and downs
peralta so you think i'm talented you
said it no take backs
you know what boyle you need to stay out
of your own head
okay but sir i don't get it if that was
your plan why bother with smitty and the
rabbit's foot
well that's a very good reason for that
i was uh i believe the term is uh
messing with you
we're becoming homies
i assembled the castle for you oh it's
over here it is
wow some jobs take dainty little fingers
you're a good dad don't put so much
pressure on yourself oh
check this out working siren
oh [ __ ] hell yeah i love that one
that's good i like those crappy other
ones
yeah one through two we're finally
getting a good one
finally raising the box
that's funny quite had some complaints
about
gina like not really complaints but not
sure how to feel about her
still not a hundred percent but she did
get me
laughing quite a bit at a couple of
lines here i've i've seen that actress
who she's she's married jordan peel
right chelsea
yeah uh yeah i've seen her in interviews
and stuff and she's really funny there
so i think uh like being endeared to who
she is when she does interviews
makes it easier for me to warm up to her
character yeah just because i like
chelsea peretti the personality
and uh yeah having her shine here was
was really cool
and i'm getting a better idea for
santiago's character as well like she's
more than just the romantic interest
other good cop yeah she's like she's
team wants to
say teacher's pet essentially is what
her character portrayal is
yeah you can feel their character slowly
fleshing out a little bit more
but overall i gotta say the idea of just
even jake
there's something i am talking into that
is creating this echo
is it this can hello yeah it's a can
that freaking bizarre isn't
an assignment i don't know if you guys
can hear it but i'm like i'm hearing
this echo into something i'm like what
is going on here
dude not bad though uh but yeah this the
the plot of just him being in a slump
i don't know that's something i kind of
feel like i needed right now
because like there's been so much
momentum with the channel lately
and then it seems like every other week
for the past like
three weeks four weeks yeah not every
other week every
every like few days or something like
frequently over the past handful of
weeks yeah there's like oh there's
a little slump right now aren't we yeah
yeah but just like that learning lesson
that mentorship
i was flashing a 30 rock in the sense of
how you have
alec baldwin and tina fey and then
that's kind of what you got
here with andy samberg and uh
captain holt you know like the mentor
and then the one who's up and coming
so i loved having that
learning lesson here of when they
brought it back around to boil
with boil of how he doesn't let
adversity bring him down that he keeps
on grinding regardless i'm like you know
what
i kind of needed to hear that today that
made me feel good and like having that
heart there
it's it's a pretty cool it's just a
pretty thing but on top of that too it's
freaking hilarious yeah it's so funny
man
this is the perfect combination for
uplift because i think like you know as
far as the
the plotting of the episode goes they
made something actually pretty nice out
of you know peralta getting stuck
figuring out what to do next and then
finally cracking it you know like
the way that the uh you know cult
inspires him by the end
is kind of applicable you know you you
go back and you go look at the thing
you've been avoiding for a little while
and then somehow you come to a
breakthrough and and yeah i thought it
was
nicely hewn even though the point is you
know like the comedy and the fun and
games i like that they
actually made that little storyline that
little arc
you know kind of a nice one you know
that you could actually take a little
inspiration from
too i love when they make these like
goofy
wacky characters show that they're
actually good at their job
yeah like what they did with hitchcock
was such an unexpected surprise i think
that's where the comedy comes in so
strong
like that's the key to a comedy i think
is you know setting up an expectation of
what you think is going to happen
and then going in a different direction
that you wouldn't
expect it really to go at least for how
the punchline would unveil right down to
like with the kids
uh and then they start chanting like as
long as that
black guy like guys like the joke sets
you up in a way
of oh no they're it's stereotyping they
think they're doing a black voice or
something like that you know
then it becomes about how it's offensive
that she's not doing a black voice
yeah that's what i mean like they
subverted it's so it's not like the
greatest subversion of expectations but
it is a variation of that
yeah and that's the kind of comedy i
think it's so strong here
like when you know the peralta handing
off the cases to
hitchcock hitchcock comes in solved four
right here he turned in all these other
people
for me and going from that whole like i
don't want to do paperwork to like i'm
not handing off this case to you man
this is going way too well for me
yeah that's brilliant stuff to me i
thought there's a lot of
it's clever you know like there's a it's
easy to chalk up
some comedy shows too it's dumb comedy
the characters are stupid like no that's
not the case what's what's cool about
this
series is these characters are all
capable they're all talented they're
skilled at what they do
but you see like there's a lot of the i
don't really know how to quite describe
it
you know like the comedy it's not
relying on them being
idiotic yeah it relies on their
chemistry and the ways in which they uh
you know cause
friction for each other or at odds with
each other but
ultimately underlying all that is a
common goal and everybody does except
for maybe chelsea
gina maybe doesn't want to excel but
everybody else wants to excel in some
way
well i think what they do with them by
making them human is yes they are
capable detectives
um however they let their insecurity
shine through
and they let that make them very human
right down to even rosa when she's
talking to the kids and she's being all
tough and they all started turning on
her and you could see that she's
her feelings are getting hurt by the
fact that they're laughing at her like
they don't have to say it but you can
see it in her expression like oh
her feelings are getting a little bit
hurt playing on the insecurities
teacher's pet andy sandberg feeling like
she he's in a slump right here when his
whole
thing is i'm really great at my job and
i don't need to be bossed around or
really told what to do
but i'm great and then it really gets to
him so and then even with uh
terry crews or terry jeffords
uh yeah going down to terry crews and
the bit that they have going with him
like i don't know forever
there's a lot of seasons yeah so i
imagine at some point you'd see his wife
and kids
but i love that you just don't right now
he's so he's a scared cop he's dealing
with his wife at home
trying to be a good dad and you never
see the [ __ ] all like off-screen
stuff that he's dealing with that is
eating at him and like making him
deteriorate i love that it's
hilarious stuff yeah and yet the side of
him we get to behold so much of the time
is still like you know this huge guy
with a lot of energy and like you know
watching him i thought this episode
actually did nicely to sprinkle that
theme for everybody because as much as
it is about peralta's slump
everyone's struggling against a comfort
zone and so you know having him even be
like you know i'm supposed to be able to
build
this and i can't you know and and this
episode to me out of the three we've
seen so far
seemed like it's starting to take
formation of the ensemble
more so in the sense that it seems like
it's pairing more people off together
and starting to go
beyond peralta being like the main
steady focus because i liked when you
got like uh
uh you know boyle and terry together or
you got rosa
and santiago together uh you know
building on those
pairings because this is like one of the
fun parts of any you know comedic
ensemble is okay what's the mix and
match going to be like and how's the
ensemble going to grow
beyond you know the main setup and
everything well i think with boyle
you know when he's he comes across so
childish and
kind of a little bit of like a the kind
of character you laugh at
um yeah a little bit of a
buffoon but in this episode
i think they really made it clear is
that he's just a
super supportive character and a very
big optimistic guy like
everything down on like jake hammer jake
rabbit
uh you know like your dramatic entrance
was that too much
nope yeah he's very supportive or he
goes up to terry builds a dollhouse and
he's like you need to stop being so hard
on yourself you're good
so i like that they took that direction
with his character yeah because i didn't
really get the
a clear sense of that i thought he was
more like all right you're
you're the the nerdy goofy cop but
you're not really
uh you're i didn't get the like this
made it crystal clear for me essentially
that
he is the this ultimate support of the
team
and the camaraderie of everyone he
always always looking out to to be
better or
bring out the best in others you know
yeah and he's really genuine in his
expression yeah yeah well the guy who
plays him is so
i've seen we've seen like a bunch of
other things oh joe latruglio yeah he i
mean he's a character
like he's been holding it down in the
character actor field for so long comedy
realm yeah
yeah and i'm a psyched i mean you know
obviously the show is well known now but
i'm psyched that he got this opportunity
because you know he's another one of
those comedians who i'm like man more
people should know this guy's name
because if you don't you've probably
seen him and cracked up at him in five
different movies at least
yeah he's great he's wonderful um all
right guys well
what did you think about this episode
leave your thoughts down below thank you
to everyone who's like we've gotten
quite a bit of like like a thousand
subscribers just from the first episode
alone i was like oh damn
there is a great choice i just wanted to
start this because i was like i like bro
i like andy sambrick a lot and
people have you know recommended this
show but i didn't expect
for a show that has been on for so long
to you know
to have to have an audience come here to
watch us
you know check this series out so thank
you guys rewatchability
and honestly it's like such a joy just
to sit here and watch the show
uh like i'm so it's a great like it's
usually the last thing we do
if we do when we do film this so to sit
down here and watch it just feels good
it feels great
so thank you guys so much for being here
subscribe if you haven't done so already
click the notification bell
hit that like button and of course last
but not least
speaking of being a super positive
support scuba steve
gotta thank this man from the bottom of
our hearts scuba you have been
around our channel our patreon for the
longest time now surprised you never
left
there's a small handful of you guys who
just haven't left your patreon
around and uh you know it's easy to just
sort of expect
guys like you to just be there because
we're just so used to you being there
it's like the beginning of our patreon
being in this moment feeling grateful
thank you for showing us support for
that long you know
gosh you're a staple of this journey by
now you know like it wouldn't be
the real rejects anything without a
little scuba steve
seriously dude i hope everything is
going well for you i hope the east coast
is treating you all right
i hope you haven't gone to jail lately i
once lied to to get out of jury
it didn't work they look for that and i
once tried you know telling a little bit
of a lie in a jury duty session
sniffing how you said oh yeah my friend
steve you know a guy who sometimes spray
paints walls specifically involving what
the case was
didn't work i wouldn't get in trouble
now i served my time on the job
you did your civic duty you could say
whatever you want discuss the case
openly
[Music]
thank you scuba for being here man you
[Music]
rock